THEO JAMES: I think Cameron
loves being married
-because he loves Daphne, so...
-Yeah.
I love my wife,
and I love my kids,
-but I love... other women--
-Drugs and hookers too.
(LAUGHS) Yeah. Exactly.
♪ (QUIRKY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Cameron loves doing
whatever he wants,
but then he also knows
he's anchored by his wife.
The minute that that could be
potentially taken away from him,
I think there's
quite a lot of fear.
I think that's sort of why
the marriage functions so well,
because the thing that he needs
is the thing that Daphne thrives
in giving.
She really likes
taking care of him.
No, they really love each other.
It's like a genuine--
You can feel that there's
something really there,
like, built on a real emotion.
Yeah, but then within that
is all that hyper-dysfunction.
I feel like you sow your oats
when you're young,
and then, you just, you know,
you get it out of your system.
I don't know.
Not sure it works like that.
JAMES:
The dinner, I think, was tricky.
Aubrey and I struggled
because we didn't know
how big to make it,
so at one point, you know,
I'm supposed to be rubbing
her leg, and I'm like...
-(LAUGHTER)
-Yeah. Yeah.
It is. It's a really
hard balance to find.
Yeah, I'm like,
"It's so impossible
not to see this happening."
Will and I, we're both like,
"Are we seeing this?"
I think other than that,
we had a really good time.
It was a lot of fun
from what I can remember.
His moral compass
is completely skewed.
Come on.
You can't be giving me looks
like that in front of my wife.
I don't care.
Where is my money?
I know, okay? Just relax. Okay,
you're gonna get your money.
Also, his sense of entitlement
is so rich
that he thinks he should be able
to do whatever he wants.
You know, that's kind of almost
the message, isn't it?
A problem with hyper-wealth
and class is he thinks
that he's entitled to everything
that he can take.
So they're sort of
a perfect match in that sense.
'Cause other than all the drugs
and the cheating,
he's a pretty okay husband,
other than being a dickhead.
MEGHANN FAHY:
Which White Lotus character
would I pick
to take on vacation with me?
I think I would take Coolidge.
Mm! Could be a laugh.
Exactly.
(LAUGH)
I'd take sweet Adam.
FAHY: Yeah, that was gonna be
my next one.
-JAMES: So nice. Albie.
-I'd take Albie.
I'd take Albie anywhere.
(CHUCKLES)
Carry on for me, yeah.
Carry on luggage.
I do prefer carry on luggage
if I can maneuver it.
It just feels
so much more seamless,
and I do love the feeling
of walking off the plane
-and just leaving the airport.
-Disappearing.
Yeah, I agree.
Never to return.
I am definitely
go with the flow.
I sort of have an aversion
to committing to a plan.
I'm very much like see
how I feel when I wake up.
What do we want to do today?
What about you?
I'm a bit of a planner. 'Cause
I hate getting to a place,
-and it disappointing me.
-FAHY: I get that.
You know, I want to go
to the place, but in a way,
it's a bit of a curse
'cause nowadays,
you can look anything up
in the world
and look up 100 reviews on it.
-Yeah, that's true.
-A strange place we live in.
-FAHY: It is.
-(CHUCKLES)
-What a shithole!
-What a dump.